Do you ever feel like it was a mistake that
you were born human? While everyone else is
dreaming about becoming the next best entrepreneur,
nurse or artist,
I've got a little secret for you; my dream
is to become a professional house cat. But
with further research, I might not have to
dream any longer.
In fact, I may be living it already.
Are you sick and tired of being misunderstood?
Here are 9 signs you're secretly a cat; one:
you're cute, small and sassy.
Have you experienced short people problems
all your life as a cat?
It's not an issue but quite normal.
People think you're adorable and cuddly but
the minute someone has wronged you, you're
not afraid to show them your claws.
This is why you're usually respected.
On the surface, you're usually calm, cool
and collected, but underneath, you're a simmering
volcano ready to explode under enough pressure.
You never forget a kind gesture though.
Two; you can't stand messiness.
Who else here can't stand a messy room?
Cats enjoy structure, consistency and routine.
Does that sound like you?
When impulse is not your middle name and you
have a high degree of self-discipline and
control, your coworkers often admire your
work ethic; clean reliable and detail-oriented.
You make a natural role model.
Before we continue the rest of the video,
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
content as well as share this video with others.
With your help, we can reach more people and
provide our support.
Now, on to point three, three; sleeping is
your favorite hobby.
Cats love to nap.
If this screams you, don't worry about other
people calling you boring.
It's not your fault you're so popular and
get invited out to so many social events,
but decline them frequently just to cozy up
in your bed.
I mean, who could resist warm sheets and soft
pillows?
Four; your curious about everything.
You might not always go out of your way to
attend parties or strike up a conversation
with strangers, but this doesn't mean you
aren't observant.
You pay attention to the world around you
and take great pleasure in examining how things
work.
This makes you a natural bookworm, scholarly
enthusiast and lifelong partner.
Five; you are protective of your freedom.
Everybody knows a cat needs no one to complete
them.
Fiercely independent, you enjoy your space
and are rather proud of being self-sufficient.
This however doesn't mean you dislike company.
Which brings us to the next sign, six; you
enjoy affection in small doses.
For others to get close to you, they have
to earn it.
You don't trust people easily, but when the
right people enter your life, you allow yourself
to be vulnerable with them.
You value the quality of your relationship
more than the quantity.
This makes you a loyal friend and romantic
partner because the minute someone hurts someone
you care about, you do everything in your
power to protect them.
This is why cats are so reliable.
Seven; you stay up when everyone else is asleep.
Do you have nocturnal tendencies?
While your neighbors are sleeping, you might
be the only one up eating ramen and watching
your favorite Netflix show.
Have no shame, this is just how you operate.
The hard part though is regretting you stayed
up the minute your alarm goes off.
Unfortunately, being a cat stuck in a human's
body requires you to go to school and work.
Eight; you're known to be picky.
Ranging from the foods you eat to the way
you are touched by others, you have specific
preferences.
Others might consider you high maintenance
but you recognize that you're not for everyone.
The right people wouldn't mind and would respect
your tastes.
Nine; people often mistake you for being indifferent.
Do you identify as an introvert?
Others may think you're reserved, unapproachable
and serious.
But if they just allow you to grow comfortable
with them, they'll come to find you're actually
playful and affectionate.
Before you know it, you'll be cuddled up next
to them and spend every waking moment with
someone you value who values you back too.
Want more fun light-hearted content?
Check out and subscribe to the Sea rabbit;
hilarious, sarcastic and a little sassy.
He's just so unapologetically himself.
If you also like this video, be sure to give
it a Thumbs Up.
As always, thanks for watching!